hey guys welcome to a brand new video
we're gonna be doing for tonight today I
have yet to do a fortnight video on this
channel but I thought I'd start doing
some for tonight I've been playing a lot
of it just like of course a lot of other
people have I'm enjoying this game it's
part one of my favourite games this year
but either way the topic of the video
today we're gonna be talking about the
bull's-eyed locations and the treasure
location for week 3 challenges but
really quickly before we start that I
just want to talk about the week 3
challenges just in case anybody has not
seen them yet I'll put an image on
screen just in case the week 3
challenges are going to be harvest
building resources with a pickaxe deal
damage would suppress weapons search
chests and jump junction land on seven
different bull's-eyes follow the
treasure map it's not B Shores eliminate
opponents in salty Springs and get to
crossbow eliminations although to be
fair this was actually changed if you go
check your fortnight right now it is
actually one crossbow elimination and
not to this image that I took from was
actually immediately as soon as the
server started for week 3 so it around
like 8:00 in the morning
obviously [ __ ] has been changes it's
about 3:00 p.m. when I'm making it to
now you only have to do one crossbow
elimination instead of two but now to
the actual part of the video for the
treasure map part all you want to do
obviously you were too snobby shores and
look at it but basically the image on
screen is where it is going to be it's
in between in the two mountains which is
actually also in between two trees as
well it's a little bit confusing all you
want to do is just go off the bus glide
into that location and you should be on
your way and done with that challenge
super quick and super simple as well
also with the bullseye challenge that is
also a pretty easy one basically there's
going to be these red bright bull's-eyes
on the ground or on the ground or on
mountains or wherever they happen to be
placed you can see them from the bus
they are really bright when you are
flying through on the bus here's an
image from Reddit by Ken Canada on
reddit so shout out to him for both the
images that I put for the map and these
locations you're a lifesaver bro thank
you for that but just go to any one of
these locations and you should see a
bright red bullseye on on the ground or
like I said on the mountains land on it
and you will get one out of seven do
that until you hit seven different ones
and you have completed the challenge for
this week like I said these are super
simple especially the bullseye one
because you don't even need to look and
it doesn't take a lot of time obviously
if you didn't watch this video for the
treasure map and you did it on your own
it would take a little bit longer but
the bull's-eyes are really bright and
obviously like I said you could see them
from the bus so they're super
to guess where they are like the video
if you guys did enjoy really does help
me out especially now that I'm starting
to do a lot more fortnight videos I got
I got another fortnight video talking
about two new skins that apparently
relieves from the game files that I'm
gonna be releasing in the next hour or
so so definitely be on the lookout for
that
subscriber for new I'm gonna start
covering a lot of fortnight weekly
challenges like this stuff since that is
some of the harder challenges in here as
well some guides and tutorials for the
game as well when they start coming out
with new stuff but like I said in the
beginning that's going to be the end of
the video guys hope you guys did enjoy
and with that guys hope you have a great
rest your day and peace out